[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's called the Virtua Fighter slash
techadon slash debtor remember this is
like they really wanted to let you know
that it had human-like motions and half
of the fight were just starting to be
going like yeah by the way on the show
today we have Dave Rubin
yeah you book lovely lovely wonderful
little sprite nipple and then we have a
half asian lawyer bill Richman is here a
quarter black care audio way too cute
Maddie makes me throw up in my mouth a
bit she's so cute
and G Morgan Jr how are you sir I'm well
how are you don't have a wine no this is
technique I get a kind of our last
Thursday show because this Thursday is
the finale to mug Club quarantine again
you can enter the promo code quarantine
you get $30 off at louder with credit
calm / Mugler but this Thursday we'll be
watching a live press briefing then
fact-checking CNN for three hours or
four hours I don't know
oh Lord but we put a lid on it please
well I'll tap out at some point the only
longer is because we just wanted to make
it to Cuomo oh yeah you got a stir
that's really where the jokes are gonna
when I'm hoping his wife as a guest
crystal is that her name what is your
name Christina Christina Cuomo Chris
Christina
sorry Christina Chris whatever I tune
you know we give away Thursday that's
right
we have a ton of guests we're going to
have Donald Trump jr. Wow I believe we
have who else do we have on the show on
Thursday hodgetwins Ryan Callen Nick
DiPaolo maybe Greg Abbott I'm not
entirely Oh that'd be great but it's
gonna be a lot of sloppy Penn it's gonna
be bit and then of course tomorrow is a
good morning mug Club and that we have
our live in-studio jaco roast
chucklewood that's right Chuck a
correspondent very nice peace symbol
that is what they used to paint on the
churches that Bolsheviks managed to
successfully close Wow you cops okay
wait it's deaf people we're getting
cannot confirm that but there we do a
few people just so you know in the live
audience it's like five people in the
corner right
so my question of the day is your points
before we move on we will be talking
about the man behind the number of 2.2
million deaths oh yes for those who are
keeping keeping in tally
not even close no so seeing how the
experts got this so wrong how much more
or less likely are you to believe them
the next time so I don't want YouTube or
Facebook to remove this like they have
content from actual doctors who are out
there in the field you know our heroes
but not if not speak out about their
actual antibody testing are you
concerned at all that this is going to
prevent people from being prepared in
the future because I'll look back on
this and say Big Ear that you're the boy
who cried coronavirus yeah sure you're
the boy who cried coronavirus yeah it
works better than we'll move on we'll
talk about all of that and why these
models weren't accurate versus
real-world data that we have available
to us now but first don't be this broad
[Music]
we can look over there can we go over
there
[Music]
[Music]
but I keep recording we're gonna show it
to social media and he's gonna care
but okay I hope both of you get the
furnace I hope you but we'd like for me
the world trying to save your life goes
to try save your life before I send you
to help I don't think she believed in
that so that I might kill you
gosh did anyone else think that that
looked like Bradley Cooper from silver
linings playbook or he's like jogging
around I don't know and I don't plan on
hitting women so in North Carolina good
thing yeah it's fake in related news I
will get to the modeling a little bit
but first in North Carolina a woman
actually people are going crazy right
now they get a little stir-crazy a woman
opened fire on cell tower workers
hundreds of feet in the air it comes
from a local affiliate Susan moose has
been charged with assault with a deadly
weapon or she was after court documents
state that she fired a 22 revolver at a
cell phone tower worker should be noted
all charges were dropped - ever when
authorities learned that the man in
question worked for Sprint justifiable
homicide not a Softbank guy little bit
of stock market humor a little bit of
Nasdaq so experts by the way they're
saying that dogs could get extreme'
separation anxiety
yeah when this corn was lob and this
comes from New York Post with such an
overload of quality time with their
families dogs are building up a huge
reservoir of over dependency they're
concerned about that now the veterinary
experts in questions they did note
however that on the other side of the
spectrum some canines will in fact just
quote need some [ __ ] space so that
they can come to my house I told you
bits not kibble also Taylor so finally
canceled all of her Taylor strip she
canceled all the you know she canceled
all over to 2020 tour days great news
yeah she cancelled both of them she
canceled both 20/20 tour dates due to
this blur on a virus and some are
calling us the worst thing to happen to
Taylor Swift fans since the AIDS
epidemic
so that was yeah
that's tough on those yeah yeah this
tough day
hits him the hardest liza minnelli for
2021 is one in the same coming new by
the way this is something that you have
you been following the outrage recently
the Star Wars is sort of been going
social justice I don't have a wife so
wait wait
they've been getting a lot of trouble
right now because they've been trying to
push people left and you store so I
guess you've been telling about this
court black sucks it's like a platform
yeah for well the news so the new Star
Wars writers the feminist writers they
actually want to and they talked about
this thing we have a clip they want more
diverse and they want representation and
they also want to learn how to be better
allies I think it's worth it if you're
in a position of hiring power or or a
green lighting power to like reach out
to people that are not like you and say
what can I do to be in Hawaii yeah yeah
that's um that's a Harvey Weinstein
secretary by the way really
oh I've worked at Weinstein for six
years
oh wow she's done yeah she and she's a
lesbian is a lesbian yeah I just think
she's safe I think that was the case she
made the wine all straight women have to
service you into a plastic ficus I'm a
lesbian
so these producers these writers are
they've been making the runs they are
satisfied with their diverse Allied
representation in the upcoming prequel
Star Wars the Empire sucks there's going
back and rewriting history
last Thursday showing a Tuesday scrap
yard and they should have stayed there
yes so you may have seen this OC you
know she thinks this is the clip that's
making the rounds but for context we
need to reintroduce it that she thinks
people should never go back to work well
we you know have this discussion about
going going back or reopening I think a
lot of people should just say
we're not going back to that okay so we
make fun of her I just we do how does
this woman how are you representative do
you think the founding fathers ever took
this into account I could have never
seen this coming I mean if they could
get into a you know horse buggy DeLorean
and travel to today and see a O CO and
we're gonna have to make some changes
all right guys get any piece of paper I
mean she keeps saying don't go back to
work but is it that what communism
requires that you have to have a smelly
bread people who are working right
everyone or but what is the whole like
we're not gonna work thing I you know I
don't think she it's lost on her
obviously and it's a that's a salient
point but it's the irony is lost her
also that a communist she'd be dead
because they killed a [ __ ] it's a
calling
yeah man now I want me to make fun of
her obviously but but aoc she does have
to her credit long history of speaking
out against oppressive tyrannical ruler
she's uh she's a regular Daniel in the
lion's den
Boyet picture can't talk yeah it's like
we get at 12 years famines pestilence I
mean get a new thing lady yeah all right
we'll just check back tomorrow and see
if God protects her or whatever
sunrise o'clock All Right see ya
[Music]
[Music]
see Oh see if God protects her or
whatever this is the new Brendon living
translator I read that very eloquent yes
church on the back in youth group just
reading that was a problem precious
moment Jews I just read the inside of
Creed album cover oh wow
turns out it was just a free ticket for
their reunion tour hey what are the
tweets of the week they're quarter black
heresy the week look we got so much
stuff a lot of a lot of wishes for good
mornings a lot of new mutt clubbers
getting their mugs Wow there with their
little one guy has a really red beard
very very good for him you know he could
he could have been a conquistador that
guy yeah dead red beards some of them
hmm some of them had red beards are you
assuming you ever been a smoke race they
already been to Spain come on I have you
know where Spain is I got Mexico I
neither confirm nor deny yes you know
this higher on mister international
there I was pointing to you half asian
bill you're the only international I
know is just loving it the wine guy not
knowing where Spain I reject your
premise your Spain is located or jet
fits Spaniards can have red hair no I
don't I have no idea what are you
arguing donkey I'm actually swinging it
you well
I'm missing that's I would be your
windmill essential pounds ax was he uses
his he was his little sidekick right
yeah yeah Sancho Panza the original Ed
McMahon showed up to those windmills
with a big-ass check so I was born in
the wrong time yes remember a lot of you
probably have forgotten but don't you I
remember I remember when the the death
the death toll was going to be two point
two million way back way back what
started all of this right
it was going to be 2.2 million deaths in
the United States 500 thousand in the UK
those were the numbers that we heard and
we had to act now just in case you think
I'm making it up the British rocked by a
startling UK report warning of a
catastrophic epidemic the same research
suggesting without any action 2.2
million Americans could die if the US
doesn't take these steps 2.2 million
Americans could die eterna borrow who
you saw on our air yesterday he wrote
two memos trying to warn the White House
that coronavirus could cost the country
trillions of dollars and kill up to two
million Americans in this fight against
a pandemic that the White House has been
warned could kill over 2 million
Americans more Americans and died at
every war since 1776 without the strict
social distancing that number could be
as high as 2 million Americans I realize
what scar scarborough looks like it
looks like a hedgehog do you want me i
don't like him so just just to be clear
the virus is not but that 2.2 million
number i was a hoax
the number you know 2.2 million bigfoot
Cavanagh rape balloon boy the greatest
moment in history when they do mer that
when the dad was interviewed that is
what happened they asked us sending us
well he told me to go hide yeah some
minimum security resort kid kid ruined
it for us whole father could've had one
hell of a book deal i want to be clear
where did this number come from because
this was ubiquitous right this is the
number that everybody believed then we
had to act and we had to take drastic
measures because 2.2 million right and
we know now that the numbers it couldn't
be possible in the united states if you
actually look at our demographics and
you look at the media it's not a
possibility here in the united states it
could have never been
ability but let me introduce you to the
founder of the feast the man who came up
with this number dr. Neil Ferguson from
the Imperial College in London he is the
one again responsible for the 2.2
million Americans will die number here
he is advocating you know China style
lock downs I will now speak with
Professor Neil Ferguson director of the
Abdul Latif Jameel Institute for disease
and emergency analytics or J idea for
short beyond those smaller outbreaks one
has to adopt the sort of community
measures which have been adopted
particularly in places like Lu Han and
China where you try to reduce contacts
between people in the community did that
camera suck his soul out of his body he
blends in with the pasty background yeah
and did you see this thing on CNN where
they they're actually sending people to
Wuhan we're supposed to celebrate like
we're able to go to work yeah the wet
markets all of it we should only reopen
it as the next Hiroshima was made the
point is Terminator 2 of course cleared
out first you know will drop some elite
force can you send me as a correspondent
awesome even you apparently build a
submitted suicide I hope you don't have
a life in you've been to Hong Kong
though right I've been many times yeah
does anyone go to there like do they
have any non worst industry doesn't
exist I can't imagine it just totally
fake just bats and diseases studying lab
so why is this important well it's
important because it's a number that we
all use but there's a real pattern here
again while we're talking about doctor I
keep forgetting his name Neal you know
what from now on I'm gonna call him Neal
for short Neil deGrasse Tyson this guy
has a pattern so we'll start with the
corona virus but this is important
because everyone has used him they've
cited him and I think this is important
to keep in mind and we talked about the
experts because everyone says this
whether you're talking about climate
change even if you're just saying hey
listen I believe the earth is warming I
believe that human beings are
considering to it I don't believe that
the Paris agreement will necessarily
change it right the same case that will
they say well right now if you don't
believe the 2.2 million Americans will
die well then why are you questioning
the experts well let me present cases to
why sometimes you should question the
experts and do your own due diligence so
let's look at the krona virus numbers he
came up with a 2.2 million number and he
refused to release the workings of the
study the model is based on a 13 year
old code that is completely undocumented
okay I want to be bitter about that and
you know what else this is like the 77
cents in the dollar with Barack Obama he
is out there saying women make 77 and
you're going to disease not have access
to to even baby even if he doesn't go
goal if he's in college could help this
guy webcrawler for crying out loud you
wonder on second why why do you why does
nobody in power have the ability to
question this number because this is the
source of the number and no one goes
okay yeah well what's your reference
there doesn't matter on economies and
you know that he has no problem with it
let's go back through all of his other
predictions ok considered an authority
an expert on the issue in 2009 this man
dr. Neil he estimated that swine flu had
a 0.4% death rate based on his advice
government UK the estimated 65,000 dead
what actually happened 457 deaths the
death rate was 0.026 person so that's a
little bit often forget about it in
financial terms for that's like saying
you're gonna make a million dollars in
profit and making 7,000 yeah just for
some context that's gonna be a crime he
closed hope you bought it before the
pandemic ceased bird flu was another one
any prediction for you guys no actually
I could say that for Ali's call us
consist the capital of the bird flu
again dr. Neil what'd he say he said to
2005 I believe right Neil Fez died what
he said in 2005 yeah 2005 he predicted
200 million bird flu deaths people not
birds people right yes people forget to
run bird flu sorry from bird flu I
should have I don't want to get
fact-checked by who I was screwing with
him
PETA they're coming for you what
happened to the good work where who they
just had a few upturned noses and some
wire left from the Grinch now they're
dominating world economy oh my god
through him so the reality there were
only a few hundred in a decade right
bird flu yes less than a hundred per
year on average and keep in mind by the
way because right now they say well all
that we a 2.2 million we even had one
hundred at two hundred forty thousand
because of the lockdowns
no actually the numbers were really
revised long before the social
distancing could have taken effect and
then again you can look here at the bird
flu this was done without massive
lockdowns you were alive during the bird
flu do you remember this kind of a crash
to the economy do you remember everyone
being forced to stay in place at home ya
know it's kind of weird to dr. Ferguson
seems like he needed to one-up the
whu-oh would like it if they weren't
quite wrong enough right they came out
and said 150 million he's like ha ha I
can beat that
yes I've got 200 just scream loud or
like a kid at a great school Christmas
pageant like he wants to do we did 2.2
million go on go on let's go on down to
Silent Night ok no by the way hit the
notification bell I should mention if
it's a notification bell if you're
subscribing inscriptions don't mean a
whole lot we're being fact-checked by
Snopes
[Laughter]
and if you can't be bothered to hit the
notification bella hit all notifications
just check back every day 8 p.m. Eastern
we have a new clip that goes up please
do consider joining it Mudd Club lot of
credit that come Celeste mullet the
promo code is still valid through April
$30 off promo code quarantine here's
another one another prediction it was
the you know that was it called like the
foot and mouth disease I don't know the
the the viral aaj achill nomenclature
epidemiology local I just heard a foot
all these well which this guy does a lot
who food mouth so it was a he had a
model right in his imperial a team at
the imperial college it's just millions
of farm animals okay hat would have to
be killed to prevent the spread even if
at the point there was no evidence of
infection okay now what happened animal
disease experts keep in mind experts so
an expert said hey this is going to
spread we have to kill all these animals
and other experts at mo they said it
looked like a they had a calling it was
necessary right because the the model
from
well turns out that actually it was not
necessary they didn't take into account
the species composition of farms this is
something that I read from some kind of
sort of an epidemiological study I don't
really know what it means but I do know
that it was too late millions of animals
have been killed it cost the British
economy 10 billion well actually twelve
point five billion American dollars well
that's some times in my head I have to
convert it them euros to Canadian
dollars and I have to convert it to
American dollars by how much we paid for
n64 games why do you go to Canadian and
then down I was raising a stupid place
rate
well you gotta call them up man you know
he's from Canada rub it in his face no I
thought it was past it if you look at
this right here where they called these
animals right it cost twelve point five
billion dollars it shows you the dr.neil
whose head comes to a point is not he's
not scary he has no problem with
destroying an economy with panic he's
done it in the past exactly I think the
the bigger thing we're leveraged arts
throwing at him is not the fact that
he's a conehead but that he's wrong and
everything that he does but he is from
the Imperial College the rest of the
experts were just from regular
universities right but in this study the
reason that they ended up killing so
many more animals is because they didn't
realize how the virus would spread
between different species right seems
like a good point be like well just the
cows well now let's kill everything I
know
cows birds you have learned the
interspecies relationships that's how
aids starts that's true or flight
attendants so that was a good on-air
correction yeah it was yes I want to
make sure I get it rest up and they're
not servers they know Garson Ferguson
made another prediction on mad cow
disease had 150,000 deaths from Mad Cow
right this was based on the theory back
then that British sheep if you remember
this British sheep might be capable of
spreading it oh yeah now to date there
have been fewer than 200 deaths from Mad
Cow in the United Kingdom none of which
have been transmitted from sheep I think
this guy just hates animals for 40 years
[Laughter]
period so it's a trump card and then
kill them on and I'll show your
descendants nice what do you think you
think with the track record like this
you know one of two things would happen
one he would shut up or two people would
stop listening
two days ago he makes a prediction that
there would be over 100,000 deaths in
the UK if they open and isolate 80% of
the elderly and immunocompromised people
if they were successful doing that
there'd still be over a hundred thousand
right UK so he's making yet another
terror and this is by the way you guys
we don't have enough time to run all the
clips you can go watch the news they're
talking about this non-stop on CNN and
BBC right now they still are citing this
guy keep in mind why is patient zero
right you trace it all the way back
where did the 2.2 million come from this
it came from this guy just like the 77
cents in a dollar came from one study
all that comes from is taking the
average salary of men across all
different lines of work regardless of
hours worked regardless of education
compared it with women it's that certain
people that well no no there must be
something more to it right because
experts wouldn't get it that wrong would
they the guy killed all the Sheep well I
wonder at what point really at what
point do you stop listening to this guy
how many times do you have to be wrong
by hundreds of thousands of people by 99
percent of my sister by the way I
appreciate you play he's plain it's like
politically now I know it is millions
was off by million virus don't
exaggerate my most conservative number
yeah millions he's off by millions I
stand corrected right now in a few point
one five million with his to point to my
the way you see what in that report that
British agency or whoever was saying it
like saying you know five hundred and
sixty thousand deaths in the UK but the
big stat was the deaths and the like we
don't put your stats like bigger than
ours right don't you care about your own
people first but it's like bold it's
because the United States matters yeah
everyone cares about that
acknowledgement by how much do you guys
know about Canada right now well yeah
more than I do you know what's going on
you have to agree these days anyone
following it since Drake left I don't
think so is he still here point no I
don't I have no idea
I didn't watch Degrassi Wow it was
Americans who kept the grass because of
the novelty of how crappy it was
Canadians didn't care I don't know and
this is this is something that I think
is important here there is listen we had
and I want to be clear I think we all
well actually think some of you guys
here wanted to pull me back a little bit
initially a second I think is a crap you
did too and actually you thought it was
partially crap but you're like let's
play it safe because we don't I get
fact-checking on air yeah yeah well I
will say that you were you were more
looking back you were more correct about
how overblown it was gonna be I was like
oh we should question some stuff but I
was definitely more drinking the
kool-aid and you were like man I don't
know we'll just check back in 16 you
were drinking my whiskey straight from
the bottle
Jameson kills it I don't think that it
does hey I asked Trump but if you're
going to shut that the best I'm saying
waterboard bill with Trump vodka
we had these I think that when in the
absence of data it was prudent to take
some precautionary measures sure yes
when we didn't know now keep in mind the
absence of data that's where people were
reaching for numbers and they said well
oh two point two million yeah and I
still think we should have quarantined
the sick you can go back and said why
don't you quarantine old people and sick
people now people are saying that back
then people's a how you monster my
listen go take any any his store anytime
throughout history go back through I
don't know times are on Christ yeah
there nope its of non lepers or lepers
you don't throw in the non lepers you
don't you them separate let the lepers
run free this is what you don't
quarantine the second but at one point
we had height we had hypothetical
numbers we needed to work with these
models and as a matter of fact actual if
you go to the website we didn't work
with those models there were plenty of
other epidemiologist who were experts
who were just considered contrarians who
said this really doesn't make any sense
it doesn't add up and we tried to cover
that we just have to be careful because
big tech gets together and it will
remove videos they remove the videos
Mike these were the names of those
doctors from Los Angeles at Los Angeles
County five million relays five million
plays they had several thousand people
who they've actually tested for
antibodies never seen the death rate
0.1%
yep got removed from Facebook because it
violated guidelines
it's fake according so we've had to try
and be consistent we've had to try and
be authentic but also we've had to try
and navigate Facebook YouTube Twitter
who by the way take their marching
orders directly from the World Health
Organization who said by the way not
that long ago that it couldn't be
transmitted through human to human
contact so when you're using them as
your Washington Post or Snopes or
Southern Poverty Law Center fact
checkers at what point you say you know
what maybe the contrarians are right
because it doesn't take a scientist or
an expert to have studied any virus ever
and said you know what I think that if
you start fondling someone who has it
that's a bad idea
it's a slippery slope it's a sweaty
clammy slope it is sniffing involved so
we have if you're the vice president of
course former vice president soon will
be dead not a threat no I just mean that
it's a degenerative disease no pleasure
in it doesn't know he's crazy
just one debate I just want to see one I
just make it you will find any reason to
avoid down oh my gosh I think what we're
seeing right now is we're seeing the
theoretical unfortunately clashing with
the real world okay so is theoretical we
could lose 2.2 million lives we could
now we're gonna revise it we could lose
a hundred thousand to two hundred forty
thousand right right right we could have
whatever how many tens of millions of
people are infected though that's
actually from some of it probably I
though they don't want to report on that
now because then all of a sudden that
lowers the death rate so we could have
those but now we have real-world data
where we've tested people for antibodies
what do we have we have New York City
Los Angeles County Santa Clara County we
have Miami Dade County we have Chelsea
in Massachusetts we have a few more I
kidding I don't have them off the top of
my head every single one has revised
their death estimates their death or
mortality rate relative to 0.5 to 0.1%
and that's including the 95% of whom are
people over the age of 80 and have
pre-existing conditions every single one
that has run these studies so you can
even say
they're getting too many false positives
with these antibody tests okay let's
double it the people who said this is
more comfortable to the flu were so much
closer than the experts who said four to
seven percent it's laughable and we have
real-world data now in that we see how
many people have died we see how
communicable it is we don't know the
extent of that but by the way all
testing shows us between four to six
percent for two I think six point five
percent depending on the county that
means that far more people have been
affected we have real world data now
that what is it twenty-two million we
had 24 million jobless claims at this
point I thought it meant liar than that
it could be it could be significantly
higher than that we have real-world data
now that one in five suicides is linked
to unemployment
we have real-world data now that we've
crippled economies we have real world
data now that 36 percent of retail
industries might not reopen after this
economy and that is clashing with the
theoretical which we know is verifiably
false but unfortunately big tech and
their overlords want to silence doctors
right now who are out there speaking to
espousing the real world observable data
at this point so at one time sure in the
absence of data I think it was prudent
to take some precautionary measures but
at this point in the face of
overwhelming data it's a conspiracy and
it's a hoax you don't have to rely
exclusively on experts sure you should
have wise counsel everybody should have
wise counsel but you should also do your
own due diligence and certainly when
faced with theoretical data or
real-world observable data commonly
referred to as actual science go with
the latter and I hope that we don't have
the wool pulled over eyes again okay we
have to get going Dave Rubin is going to
be right up after this
oh hi seen on the board do you guys have
black rifle coffee here no I'm sorry we
only carry good small batch coffee here
well it is great
small batch coffee well that really
can't be unless it's fresh roasted so
you know what is fresh roasted oh thank
you know what that means you know what
this is this is masala quoi PK which of
course in the Indonesian Maya let me
finish and the Indonesian language it's
weasel coffee u smade that up no it's
been passed their digestive tract that's
discussed and then it's nature's why
processing
yeah is it good I mean it's alright are
they investor philanthropist today
support good causes yeah that's it
causes veterans causes and your first
responder causes but it doesn't matter
cuz they make good coffee so that's what
I'm wondering do you have any you know
what actually I'm you're just gonna
order it then they get freshly roasted
all right black rifle coffee it's good
flackville coffee calm slash Crowder
entering promo Co Crowder you get 20%
off and it's important by the way to
note that they've donated I think over
20,000 bags of coffee with their buy a
bag give a bag campaign a veteran-owned
it is a it is a lot of coffee and they
also just launched a new brand of canned
coffee that you can kind of add your so
you can get it online 200 milligrams of
caffeine per can it's coming from
natural cup like as protein and I
haven't had any they haven't sent me any
but I hope you enjoy it I'll black rifle
coffee calm slash Crowder they have the
balls to sponsor the show and if you
drink coffee just drink better coffee
from a company who gives a rat's ass
[Music]
oh right glad to have it well we've had
this gentleman on her show quite a bit
yeah and then I was on his show
initially many years ago the reaction
was not positive but that's because he
was I think he was sort of earlier on he
had left the Young Turks and was
becoming I don't want to say more
conservative but was was speaking out
against sort of the modern progressive
left taken out yes yeah we don't use
that term anymore because we're not
Nazis apparently so apparently those are
only a lot of Bernie's so you can follow
him on the Twitter at Rubin report he
hasn't been banned yet and of course you
know he could he hosts a show over there
place TV and you know if you are a mug
club member he has a new book though
called don't burn this book we did there
oh I don't like I've burned a lot a
little bit it's still worthwhile how are
you sir Crowder I'm doing good and it's
funny you give me that kind of intro
because in the old days when I had you
on whatever that was like four years ago
I mean it's kind of crazy
it's like sings always been we've been
trying to do it in person which is why I
haven't had you on igano although at
this point you know obviously what we'll
do it over Skype whenever you want but
it's kind of funny because the hate that
I got for having you on at the time when
people thought I was a good lefty and I
was just testing the waters with these
scary conservatives it's like that level
of hate that I got then that is a barely
a trickle relative to the torrent that I
became accustomed to over the last five
years as as I've sort of opened up
politically and you know created some
new alliances and said goodbye to some
old thoughts and games like that so
those were the good old days well you
know I think the reason for it like
obviously at that point I think you'd
had you know Milo was around and you had
had a few guests who were sort of more
right leaning some or more libertarian
but I just wanted to be honest and I
think what happened was you asked me
about you know I was I was very
straightforward about being pro-life and
you asked me about same-sex marriage and
I said yeah I don't I think it's a state
thing I said I just don't live I don't
think that the government should mean
that you're turning business and I don't
think that marriage is a fundamental
human right for any one civil union sure
but no and people just lost their mind
I remember talking making the argument
back then that listen the challenge with
this as we had in Canada is once you
declare marriage a fundamental human
right
if churches or mosques or synagogues if
their religion doesn't recognize it then
they can be sued and jailed has happened
in Canada and of course we've seen some
of that now since with private
businesses so what didn't mean that I
didn't think that you're lovely and I
still do I mean I don't know how lovely
I think you are but I think you are
astute politically and made a good point
about the government's involvement in in
gay marriage and and the state arguments
an interesting one and I do a lot of
state argument stuff in this book but of
course the broader point of if you want
to live in a society with people that
are different from you and you want to
allow people to have some religious
beliefs and some secular beliefs and the
whole freaking thing well you have to be
able to you don't have to actually
respect their beliefs but you have to
let them have them so it's why I've been
able to have a friendship with ben
shapiro who takes an Orthodox Jewish
perspective on gay marriage so guess
what Ben's not gonna get gay married and
that's okay and and yet he's not coming
for my marriage and that's the exchange
that we have in such an incredibly
beautiful way in America and more
broadly in the West but I think
specifically in America we have
something so unbelievably great here
that so many people are so just play
with so dangerously as to how we could
throw it away yeah I don't think people
understand that this is uniquely
American and being raised in Canada was
very acutely aware of the fact that
speech free speech was not a luxury that
we had in Canada and they certainly
don't have it really anywhere in Europe
so let me ask you this I know you you
talk about this in your book and I want
to get to how some of the writings in
your book that you I believe you
finished last July
almost clairvoyant to what we're seeing
now with states rights as it relates to
Kovac Ovid the coronavirus out who flew
whatever you want to call it but when
you started back then you were sort of
you had you had left the left right and
you were sort of disenchanted with the
Young Turks and the radical progressive
left but where are you now like if you
have to state what are you after having
toured with Jordan Peterson more
definitively not what you've left but
what who is Dave
now in his own words like politically Oh
crowd are getting to the heart of it
right at the beginning I was always
curious no and you like we both like
dogs we concur on that - I literally
have a dog sleeping on my feet right now
so like it's a great question I will
answer it I will just say one thing
first which is that you know it's funny
because when I started my show so right
around when I had you on at the
beginning so this is when I started the
interview show it was September of 2015
so that's not that long ago it's less
than five full years ago I at first
never said I left the left I was really
still fighting for my side what I
thought was my side I was going guys
guys we can't silence everybody buddy we
can't mob everybody we can't outrage
destroy everybody let's be more open and
actually liberal like we're supposed to
be and then suddenly what happened was I
found all of these other people that
were having similar thoughts from a
lefty perspective that then led me to
write all of the scary guys like you and
Shapiro and back in and everybody else
yes I'm a sister so truly answer your
question I would say look I lay out what
I believe are classical liberal
principles in this book that that are
the right principles to govern by which
are individual rights
I want everybody that is a legal citizen
of the United States to have exactly the
same rights regardless of your gender
your skin color your sexual orientation
where you're from etc etc and then and
then I want lays a fair economics that
we should always try to do everything
without government involvement and then
I do recognize and this is why I would
say I'm not a full libertarian I do
recognize that sometimes unfortunately
you have to have the government involved
to put some guardrails on of course yeah
sorry so I would say look I think that
very much still fits in within the
definition of a classical liberal but am
i trying to revive a phrase from several
hundred years ago in a certain regard
because the word liberal I always say
this to you it's like when you talk
about liberals you mean leftist but I
get it the word liberal has just been
like yeah battered and bludgeoned or
whatever so I will say something that I
haven't said before but I've been
thinking about a lot lately I would say
if you can accept this term I think this
is probably what I am I'm probably a
liberal can
service meaning meaning meaning that I'm
with you I'm with you on most of the
stuff the foundational society stuff but
I still do have things that I think
conservatives wouldn't be thrilled with
so you know I make a begrudging ly
pro-choice art I don't want to have a
webcam in your bedroom if that's what
you know I think that's something people
get wrong with conservatives because of
how they govern the how they govern
their families you know but here's
something that I appreciate you saying
that and it is it is different there's a
journey here's one thing that I'm
curious it kind of as it relates to what
you've just said I understand when you
say you know classical liberal I
understand how you go from being
obviously you're a gay man and free
speech being really important to you
being in a country where you go listen
as a minority right it's obviously very
important for you to be able to speak
freely free to fight for equal rights so
I understand that transition because the
left the current left is not for that
but how does the transition happen from
where you were more liberal left-leaning
back then financially because policy
yeah that's that is a change that is is
notable and it has got to be a tough one
to make that's not an easy one like it's
not popular I can give you a seriously
granular answer on that is which is look
sit down with Thomas Saul a couple times
yeah and and read a couple of those
books and talk to some really
interesting conservative libertarian
economists but more than anything else
and that that is by the way when people
say to me what have you really shifted
on yes I've seen as much except except
for economics and the reason I've
shifted for economics not only because
I've listened to the clear and cogent
arguments that have been made by Thomas
all and many others but really because I
am a small businessman now I run my show
as you know I own my production company
we have we about six or seven full-time
employees I've got some part-time
employees we pay everybody well we pay
for a hundred percent of their health
insurance we gave all my guys bonuses
during kovin because they're busting
their butts for me and I now know as a
small businessman I live in Los Angeles
in the People's Republic of California
we are taxed to a hilt it's insane what
we're taxed by here the fact that I'm
doing business here instead of instead
of where you are is is slightly nuts
so you shaved off some IQ points on this
journey if you're still in California
weather is nice it's not as humid but
what that means you have mark Ovid right
humidity and heat kills it so again
another reason 85 percent 80 percent
humidity 95 degrees it's that they say
in humidity kills I thought nice dry
heat no no no it was I don't think we
don't have the overlay right now but it
was a different sort of reference ranges
and I think it was if it's 75 degrees
and 60% humidity it takes a few hours
and it was something like airborne
coronavirus particles not on a surface
in 95-degree heat or hotter than 80
percent humidity last 60 seconds oh man
so so like Houston or the Florida
Panhandle basic subway yeah
well the New York subway can be quite
humid and hot so you know that's true
but but truly I mean by running my own
business and by applying the thoughts
that I was talking to talking to Thomas
all talking all these people I started
applying those thoughts to my own
business and my business has flourished
we we have no debt were surviving we're
actually thriving right now and as I
said to you right before we started I
mean I was a little ahead of the curve
on the home studio thing this is my
garage right and I know that if the
government gets out of my way the stupid
things I've had to do related to
regulation and lights and air
conditioning and all of that and and how
much more it costs to operate a business
here in California versus in Texas or in
Florida or elsewhere and the simple fact
beyond anything else if my taxes are cut
does that mean I'm gonna frickin buy a
bajillion Bentleys well I can't afford
them anyway but it's not that although
it would be my right to do it I know if
my taxes were cut right now you know
what the first thing I would do is it's
hire more employees I would give more
people more jobs that is a bit wasn't my
first really good it's your money man do
what you want with it and so that is the
one thing I would say I've shifted on
the most what if I would like to
purchase an exotic pet or like a like a
funny hat zany I'm okay with both of
those tigers are very hot right early
I heard finding that out I just assumed
that when I was a kid that you couldn't
buy Tigers because that's like no I want
to be a dad said that's illegal it's
like oh I guess I'll never have a tiger
and then I found out it's only three
thousand dollars almost everyone I know
has a tiger really
well that's because you hang out with
Siegfried and Roy so I ask you what what
do we what can we expect in this but
don't burn this book nothing can nothing
be kept secret between us I mean I say
this out of love it's a liability the
guy got mauled by the Tigers and by the
way when people said like in a shocking
turn of events yeah I think I lived with
24/7 and he was screwing with them
taking pictures I'm like as far as I'm
concerned you're on borrowed time it's a
shock you know you know we got attacked
by a tiger Siegfried the tiger spectacle
issed
right right like if you had been working
with doves as a magician if you had been
working with doves and a tiger came out
of the wing first off is this and I know
this could be auto censored on YouTube
is the book flame retardant before we
get into the what's inside well crowd
are little known fact did you know that
Ray Bradbury called Fahrenheit 451 451
because 451 is the temperature that
paper birds you know that remake that
was awful on HBO where did you see that
I thought I my god and everyone's
everyone's burning that they're like
they're all burning the Koran and then
they're not burning I don't member what
it was it was just really bad sorry okay
so the flame returned other the other
Michael Jordan that's a tough name to
have yeah especially like if it was a
really white Michael Jordan they're like
totally annihilated that would be okay
no we have not tried to burn it although
we did try to get a copy that was going
to be flame retardant so that it would
be fun if we tried to light it on fire
but it would not light off right but
trust me man I am waiting for some some
social justice warrior is gonna burn
this thing
yeah really by titling it don't burn
this book the real ID
here of course was that the stuff that I
lay out here whether you agree with 100%
of it or not it is almost irrelevant if
really in my opinion is some common
sense stuff and we can disagree on some
of the margins of course we can but the
idea is that the New York Times will not
be happy about this book CNN will not be
happy about this book the social justice
worries were not be happy and it's not
because I'm laying out far right
craziness or even or even just
conservative stuff it's because I'm
laying out common sense and in many ways
that's become their their kryptonite
common sense is not what they're in the
business of they're in the business of
keeping everyone hysterical all the time
and I'm trying to give a little antidote
to that you talk quite a bit I know in
your book about states rights and as
you're more of kind of like you said a
liberal conservative which frankly we'd
probably be pretty close on the
political compass test it had me
unconservative but more libertarian than
conservative down in that bottom right
quadrant I think actually if we if we
really whittled down everything that the
two of us believed I think the only one
that we'd really get to an impasse at
for now is the abortion one and in my
abortion chapter I I mean again I say
I'm a grudgingly pro-choice I just
believe that in a pluralistic society
you have to err on the side of the
people that are here and there now to a
degree and I don't deny that it's life
and the rest of it and by the way that
the abortion chapter ends with me saying
now that you all hate me let's move on
into your penchant for murder or
bloodlust but I do want you talk about
states rights quite a bit obviously and
that's a big part of your trampa sort of
transformation and right now that's at
the forefront right with a coronavirus
so I mean maybe kind of talked us
through that and what what your
viewpoint is here because the argument
is you know the greater sort of public
good versus states autonomy well it's
kind of funny because right now you know
the lefties who have been screaming for
four years that the guy in charge of the
government is Hitler and his supporters
his supporters or Nazis those are also
the people who always want the federal
government to have all the power to do
everything and it's like maybe you don't
want the Hitler guy to have all the
power let's work this thing through but
they're not very good at like the second
and third order things right look this
the Constitution federalism our founders
believed that America really was as
dennis prager calls it an experiment and
the experiment was could we have these
different states that would be governed
by their own people have governors have
senators have state representatives that
could do the best thing for their states
but yet could we be part of something
that was that was cohesive that had a
national ethos and the rest of it could
we make sure the states wouldn't be
warring with each other or trying to
destroy each other or the rest of it
we've done that incredibly well for over
200 years but what's interesting is that
when you talk about states rights like
me and you I guess could get into like a
wonky conversation about states right
but nobody really talks about states
rights and suddenly because of
coronavirus yeah the average person the
average lefty is subtly going wait a
minute wait a minute I live in New York
and New York has a unique problem
because of population density in New
York City and the Greater New York City
area is a real issue yeah there's a real
issue there related to public health but
actually I'm pretty sure that if you
live in Montana you might be able to
open up quicker and allow more people to
go back to work and the rest of it and
that is because of states rights yeah so
I'm actually pretty pretty excited that
one of the things that I believe in most
that this experiment of one state can
have high taxes California once they
could have low taxes Texas but that
maybe will affect your the money that
can go into education or whatever it
might be some states have legal
recreational marijuana some don't right
that's a beautiful thing that we're
constantly tinkering it's like we're in
a science experiment right we're
constantly going oh does this work does
it not work and and Colorado is the best
example of this they legalized
recreational marijuana and we had a lot
of people this was more people on the
right that were going this is going to
destroy society this is gonna oh you
know all of this stuff and what happened
well tax revenue went up and there's no
evidence that crime went up there's no
evidence that there's been a urban decay
or any of it and then maybe a
conservative will will rethink their
position on it because I've always been
Pro states rights on merit not only
marijuana but heroin but I've also at
one point this is my transition I said
what do you want heroin as well so
that's even you're even more libertarian
and on that
and I don't give a rat's ass but my
issue is my issues I said well listen to
the things we don't have a way of
testing for it and that's a danger with
people driving and that is something
that's undeniable in Colorado with
traffic fatalities and it's tough to
know how many of them are THC induced
because of how long it stays in the
bloodstream but until they figured out
that problem that is something that now
hopefully other states can look to say
okay we can look at a tax revenue we can
look at how maybe it's structured and we
need to figure out the traffic
fatalities and then it'll get better in
States will adjust yeah a lot of people
never understood that about myself where
I was like yeah listen I don't think
that doing a bunch of drugs is good and
I don't think that it's always even
great for society to legalize it but
that's kind of the risk that we take and
the price that we pay and I think that
Wyoming has the right to say no we're
not going to allow it so yeah Crowder I
love the fact that you just came out as
more libertarian than even me on the
heroin thing because I I mean I talk
about drugs in the book obviously and
basically I agree you you want to
maximize people's ability to do whatever
they want so I'm for legalizing
marijuana if the states so choose to do
it I'm for legalizing medicinal
mushrooms I mean a bunch of stuff but
for me the harder drugs at some point
their effect on society then disagree
with you like I don't want your
next-door neighbor to be whacked out on
crack in hair I don't want to walk down
mushrooms what the hell this is coming
for you yes absolutely absolutely and I
tell you what I get the heroin thing
I've never done heroin but anyone who's
been on morphine like Boehner made
heroin right they still get heroin in
some hospitals it's a painkiller but
there's no performance enhancing benefit
to mushrooms again states can legalize
it I've seen people go out of their mind
on mushrooms are you sure on mushrooms I
think you might be talking about acid
which is synthetic by the way mushrooms
are completely natural I mean I've done
mushrooms I know many people that do
mushrooms people on mushrooms you go you
wander in a park for five hours you
think about the universe and then you go
to bed and you wake up and you feel good
that's it not every violent mushroom
nobody's mushrooms I'm gonna go do some
stuff sure that happens
you have some guys who smoke weed and
they rip people's faces off and I just
think we need to be honest about the
risks and legalize them but I in
anecdotally I have only seen heroin
people who they nod off and people on
mushrooms lose their minds now it
doesn't mean that's the rule for
everyone but just because it's natural I
mean so is hemlock but we're getting off
here man here's what I will say mr.
Ruben you do need to leave California
and you do need to move to Texas of
course because obviously a wonderful
folks at the blaze who we both work with
are there but if you do that if you move
from the hellhole that is California
because of our taxes because of our laws
because of our liberty and you come to
Texas and you vote and you start voting
blue and turn the state purple outer I
will crucify you upside-down without
breakfast it's it's so funny you say
that because whenever when I was touring
with Jordan Peter Center if I do stand
up in the middle of the country that
always becomes like a running theme like
I say to these people I'll be in Utah
I'll be like you know I kind of I kind
of dig it here maybe I'll come to Utah
maybe I'll come to Salt Lake City maybe
I'll come to Dallas and people are like
they'll applaud and then suddenly
someone in the crowd will be like but
don't bring everybody else it's true
yeah I think other states really are
fearing that and they're by the way it's
legit I mean there are there have been
some studies on the amount of people
leaving California that then go to Texas
and have I mean look Ted Cruz almost
lost a frickin better o'rourke that is a
that is a crazy proposition for Texas to
have to confront but like I'm fairly
certain I can tell you a Crowder that if
I move to Texas you're gonna be ok
engine no and don't try and play
trickery here and say oh I don't vote
Democrat and then like vote Jesse
Ventura when he gets into the green
party that won't fly either
I went through my Jesse Ventura face the
facts all right we do have to get going
this book of courses don't burn this
book where is it available for people to
find and hopefully get it to the number
one there Crowder they said to me don't
launch a book in the middle of the
biggest worldwide pandemic in decades if
not centuries I said no no we're gonna
do it you guys can get it at don't burn
this book calm it's on Amazon of course
we got an audiobook we got
the audible the whole shebang Barnes and
Noble wherever you get a book you got
your local bookstore they're over there
in Texas they've got that notice here
it's 2020 but I appreciate you plugging
it there's actually I will tell you this
next up there's a there's a Barnes &
Noble Cafe no books very variable so
that's the only Barnes Noble that I know
of in my area but everything they will
deliver it to you okay perfect all right
well mr. Rubin of course it is don't
burn this book at Rubin report thank you
for making the time brother be safe wash
your hands but seeing in my friend and
start looking for some real estate
[Music]